for weeks anastasiya you diva has been
receiving threatening phone calls that
collectors are telling her they will
hurt her child or family if she doesn't
pay back her loans she lives in a town
two hours drive from Moscow and the
salaries there are so long that she
can't afford the rent she was offered
loans despite being a single mother
without a steady job but with high
interest rates she's been unable to pay
them back I'm disappointed in myself but
it's true that these loans are available
to everyone and it's very bad there are
a lot of such stories I think I managed
to deal with this emotionally because I
have a child and I need to fight for his
sake but I heard very tragic stories of
people who commit suicide I heard a lot
of these stories thousands of credit
companies have opened up in recent years
with many offering so-called fast cash
online a recent survey shows that 39
percent of Russians believe they only
paid about half what they deserve for
the work they perform to help people to
get better jobs Moscow has started a
pilot project that offers advice
training and psychological support to
250,000 people who have fallen below the
government standard of living the
Mozilla makrina praised me and the first
thing we do is to clarify the situation
what has happened to them and that their
income is lower than the living standard
what is their psychological condition
their qualification level and if it
corresponds with the job market do they
have a motivation and what their needs
are since it opened three months ago
22,000 people have visited the center
most are women staff here say men are
less inclined to look for help because
they feel poverty as a taboo Vladimir
Putin has promised to have the number of
people living below the poverty line by
the end of his term five years from now
but some economists say this is
unrealistic since the economy has to
grow at least three times as far to be
able to achieve this and they say low
oil prices and sanctions imposed on
Russia are only part of the problem and
structural changes are needed
Putin has criticized his government for
working too slowly on
national projects aim to increase state
spending but even if they're implemented
efficiently some economists don't
believe they will fix Russia's economic
problems yet what happening is
unreasonable distribution of the revenue
and mistakes in the budget planning I
think until the paradigm changes the
geopolitical paradigm and the political
paradigm on the top the poverty will
remain at the current level we know that
despite all the new national projects
the State Statistics Agency had to
report that the level of poverty hasn't
decreased but even increased this year
when anastacio couldn't see a way of
clearing thousands of dollars of debt
she decided to look for help on the
Internet her emotional letter is typical
of many that now can be found on Russian
websites the advice she got is to file
for bankruptcy but even if she did that
she still need a job that pays for her
one-bedroom flat step fasten al-jazeera
stupido Russia